you're from Conyers Georgia are you sir
and you go back there often I do
we just had our high school reunion back
in November and that was fun I get to
see my family every once in a while so
that's what's Conyers I know a little
bit about Georgia I studied the South in
school and I'm curious what Scott that's
true I studied the literature of the
American South and the history of the
American South I don't know much about
Conyers what's its claim to fame well we
have a couple things we had an epidemic
of syphilis a few years ago a few years
ago like seven or eight yeah oh wait a
minute I thought you were talking or say
like in 1885 how many years ago I don't
know like 98 1998 okay the big severe
okay you claimed you weren't there and
what's the other claim to fame besides
throwing syphilis all over the place
we had a resident who would talk to the
Virgin Mary on the side of her barn once
a month
uh-huh who doesn't have yeah though I
mean everybody's got that in their town
right Virgin Mary the Virgin Mary shows
up everywhere she's a real Chatty Cathy
yeah
so show up on a slice of banana bread
somewhere did-did-did tourists come by
from all over the world
yeah yeah that happens when they Virgin
Mary's yeah like everybody wanted to
hear what she had to say but they would
all be all these Yankees coming down to
Conyers and stuff and then they go to
the restaurant I was working at and
they'd be screaming at me because they
didn't know the food we were serving
what kind of food were you serving fried
okra Brunswick stew
what's Brunswick's do her laFonda Smurfs
a lot you were at your you do a great
that's a great public service
announcement for Conyers Georgia Smurfs
the last village you play clumsy Smurf
is that right other do you feel like you
captured the the role of the clumsy
Smurf I mean both of all what's Clumsies
deal yeah why is he clumsy always clumsy
yeah I thought maybe it was a family
name Oh for guys why do y'all bring
people on this
why do you keep it Andy and I are having
a nice chat you keep interrupting your
the problem here the other one trying to
push this movie on yeah yeah voiced your
Smurfs crimes upon us you research the
role of clumsy is that right should I
even ask about this didn't throw myself
down a set of stairs or no then like
it's a smurf and I do a voice okay might
have helped you with that role garsh
anywho I regret all of this
[Applause]
you